Taliban are living probably in the 90s
sister they have to set with the Afghan
people they have to accept with the
Afghan government if they want to reach
peace with this I mean how long more
this can continue I think if there is
only one one red line and that is the
woman's right not only is there a
seemingly unending war in Afghanistan
there's also extremely bad blood between
the Afghan government and the Americans
who's supposed to be on the same side my
guest this week is NASA and Isha
Afghanistan's ambassador to Switzerland
and to the United Nations here in Geneva
how did his governments relations with
Washington sink so low and who's to
blame
[Music]
now Sara and Isha welcome to conflict
zone I'm not as northern a stranger to
conflict soon but you're welcome you've
had presidential elections again once
again there have been allegations of
widespread fraud who can have confidence
in the results of these elections when
they when the results come yes you know
we had an election despites
intimidations despite all of the threats
which was posed by the Taliban and also
a lot of naysayers so crude I'm just you
know coming to this but but having an
election and the situation in
Afghanistan shows the resolve of the
Afghan people to decide their fate
democratically but the question of you
know irregularities in the elections
which has been in the past also in
Afghanistan unfortunately so far the
reports that I have received is that
that it has been a much much better
election than before so who accepts the
results who says that I think all if you
look at the only independent observers
of this election they are telling us
giving you know the new regulation the
mechanisms the biometric devices this
election has been working in many places
that's the technical technical issue so
it's not just the technical issue its
reluctance of people to use them so you
see it's just it's a learning learning
process but but coming to the results of
the election it's they both can't them
in all the candidates but including the
both frontrunners have been very
categorically clear that they will
accept the result of this election
announced by the Independent Election
Commission wouldn't it that would make a
change if they accepted the results
because there was a lot of negotiation
that had to take place in 2014 which was
also marred by massive fraud as were
last year's parliamentary elections as
well so you don't you
have a good record here the system is
completely rotten isn't it you see it's
as I say it you know it's a learning
process
my or the sticks and the other sticks of
money observers and Afghanistan should
be that are we doing better than the
past or it's getting worse so I will say
this election is much better than the
previous election I mean last month we
had the former heads of the Election
Commission and the electoral Complaints
Commission both jailed for fraud along
with eight members of their staff how
many other people are involved in fraud
right up and down the country
how many see you see that also again
show you the result of this state that
that you know the election fraud will
not will not go easy with that so I
think that's that's part of building
strong institutions but if you look at
the case of tip of the iceberg the tip
off it and then we will get to the
bottom of it to the New York Times
reported that in case our district in
Faryab province one of the elders told
them the local strongmen had been
stuffing the ballot boxes they sat
together and each filled the boxes for
their guy they said we can't leave these
boxes empty we said but what about the
biometric verification they said who's
gonna look it's that kind of attitude
isn't it I seen that it's doubtless
being multiplied many many times pass
the country many times you see them you
know in Afghanistan now it's sixteen
years that we are doing election so as I
learned this 160 years where you know
where we have this interview and I asked
the Swiss that you know how to be honest
you see it depends on you know how you
build institutions and you build a trust
within the decisions the the case that
you have mentioned of course it's a
report by New York Times I don't have
the verification of it but even if that
is accurate
it shows that you know people do they
still trust the institution and who can
make the institution's trustable is the
the central estate you know the
government in Kabul and that's why you
know they put those those commissioners
into the trial we are introduced the
most you know
advanced system of which people aren't
using ambassador in another district in
Ganga ha known as a person and the
Speaker of the Senate and a County
loyalist issued a direct threat to the
chief of the Election Commission on
television after she said only the
biometric they checked votes would be
counted his response on television was
we will force even her daddy to count
the non biometric votes great to see how
powerful people are just tearing up the
rules and making them as they go along
but subsequently he apologized and he
apologized to the head of the Election
Commission and again it shows a change
in a country like Afghanistan where a
powerful person like the president of
the Senate apologizes to a woman who is
the head of the Election Commission of
Afghanistan I think that shows a change
of attitude I'm not saying that you know
it's perfect you take that as progress -
I do you know as a person who lives in
Afghanistan and I've seen you know
you're touching at straws aren't you you
see when you're in our situation you do
that your president said the election
was needed to give the new president a
powerful mandate but there is no
powerful mandate to be had in
Afghanistan is there certainly not by
elections fact is the power real power
in your country is not through
Democratic means but by a feuding
fractious collection of strongmen
warlords corrupt officials and they
don't have much use for democracy do
they wasn't under case in the Europe in
the past I mean how the centuries do you
want to go back we're living in in 2019
I think that's the difference between
Europe and our country so we are moving
in that direction torture forced
disappearances intimidation this kind of
thing that goes
in your country and you compare it to
Europe no of course of course not what
I'm saying is that look you know by the
time that Europe progress in this path
there was no conflict zone or hot talk
or somebody to make them in our County
so they are moving on their own pace but
what do we do is we don't want to move
on that pace we don't have that time but
we need you know the perseverance we
need the assistance we need you know the
good models and modalities and
technology to help this country move
along this may be quicker faster but it
might not happen in 16 years moving
backwards ambassador I mean you take the
media which blossomed for a while after
the Taliban were overthrown a hundred
media outlets have been forced to close
as human rights put it
Human Rights Watch put it threats and
abuse by government officials warlords
and security forces together with
devastating attacks by groups tied to
the Islamic state
the Taliban other insurgents all this
have forced more than a hundred media
outlets to close what are the enormous
step backwards isn't it so yeah it
basically is is it is it that systematic
is it the government policy that you
know we are clamping down on media no
you know it's but you're not clamping
down on the Warlord's either no we do we
are in a fight we are in a war we are
clamping down on the international
terrorists which is the enemy of all of
the world but at the same time we are
trying to reform our institution where
we can reduce the power of these strong
people the people that you've had in
power President Ghani Abdullah Abdullah
chief executive what have they done
they've they've completely set up a
structure which is beset by divisions
internal disagreements discord
crisis group said political partisanship
has permeated every level of the
security apparatus undermining the
command structures of the Afghan
national defense and security forces so
far from unifying the country these two
figures have actually divided it even
further for the benefit of their
personal ambition something you see
depends on which angle you're looking at
it probably crosses
crisis will be looking it from the mayor
very sort of perfectionist angle yes
you know we we have experiences of the
countries just give me an example of
other national unity government which
has you know completed their terms the
state does not we can play what about
games forever we're looking at Afghan
list but then you have to put it in
perspective we we had Libya you know
going for this kind of election a
divisive election was there we have two
governments there we are Syria which you
know taking talking in Afghanistan and
isolation will not help because you have
to look at them to see how we are
looking at this situation we are looking
at situation in Afghanistan that is the
states and institutions deflecting
attention from what's going on in your
country but it doesn't help to look at
Syria melibea what I'm saying is you're
not responsible for Syria might be but
crisis group also have a yardstick which
is you know they have they have you know
measures that okay this government this
country is betting that but they're
doing better than the other country so
that's why I'm comparing it yes our
national unity government has its own
problems the two rival teams with the
two different they no way of thinking
about governance one about a little bit
no decentralized other about the
centralized government they came
together actually to keep the state
together and prevent the computers
together when you're having shootouts
between government forces and and
warlords were supposed to be on the same
side but at the same time you know
you're fighting an insurgency yeah even
if there wasn't an insurgency you still
be at war with your own people you see
as I said that you know it depends we
are know he is fighting the Taliban you
still having shootouts with your own
people I mean in a situation like
Afghanistan you know what what what do
you expect you know what we say that you
know the Americans will say that you
know we chew gum and walk you know we
fight the rest of money money
divisions we have Isis there we have
Taliban you know Connie Network but at
the same time also we have people who
wanted to keep the government weak so
you know we are the government is freak
isn't it the government is weak and it
fails and to take measures against
prominent people who they could make an
example of let's take the case of the
former governor of Panjshir province
Karamu didn't carry an arrest warrant
was issued for him in the summer after
multiple allegations that he sexually
assaulted women when he was president of
the country's Football Federation why
hasn't he been arrested and formally
charged so he was charged removed from
his position his case is now in the
attorney general's office probably he is
not in the country I mean inside we have
many cases where even international
community has not helped us the
suggestion from Human Rights Watch is
that he continues to wield considerable
influence among the police and other
politicians and that's why he got off
that's why you could have seized his
property couldn't you I think that's
Tony junglers case I had I don't have
that details but I can assure you that
that no he does not feel any any power
right now and cup the Americans have
criticized your inaction in the
strongest possible terms the Ambassador
John bass said in June we call on the
government of Afghanistan to complete
its investigation and in short justice
is served support of that investigation
to the ten part of that investigation we
send even a team here to to meet FIFA
they went to Germany yes you have a case
it's cannot it's not like you know you
you collect you know you have to collect
everything it has to be strong because
it's an international case right now
there are international lawyers in this
we cannot you know have an abrupt
justice in this case we're late around
some other courts will come against it
so we take all the you know the
the due diligence we send the legations
of our attorneys in these countries to
in the rest you've issued an arrest
warrant now pick him up this is all the
Americans as I see you shall give an
example you know how long will it take
for those photo needs to get the visa
for this Western countries I'm talking
about the same case because Peters case
fussing with the rule of law don't you a
real problem exercising the rule of law
you see yes you know we have problem
with the rule of law but but exercise of
rule of law requires a strong state and
that is what we have to build you also
have a big problem with torture and that
is perhaps the worst aspect of your
government's failure on the human rights
front hasn't it tortured by your
security services and their affiliates
time and again Western agencies have
reported the appalling treatment
inflicted by your officials and local
allies on prisoners why do you so
consistently fail to crack down on these
disgraceful practice can you can you
give me such sticks on this because what
I asked as far as I'm he heard in past
six month in our records on this because
we have recently joined the optional
protocol of cat which is Convention
Against Torture so which allows even the
cases to be taken to any course and it
allows for the investigators to get into
even our prisons I think that is the
most open part of this convention latest
report which say that there is a
reduction there is substantial reduction
in the cases of this especially you know
in areas which was in you know in India
is you still have a third of conflict
related detainees alleging serious abuse
including severe beatings electric
shocks near suffocation and suspension
from the ceiling for long periods and
that's from the enamors latest report so
what what does all this say what does it
say about you that you these practices
continue year after year after year when
they're flagged up year after year
we do we definitely do look I probably
charge focaccia look at those statistics
of you nama which will tell you there is
27 percent reduction in the cases which
is alleged torture and Kandahar yes in
Canada including in Canada the latest
report called the numbers watch it in
Kandahar staggering staggering it said
this in facilities under the control of
the main Intelligence Agency the
National Directorate of security do you
do yoga does your government actually
control this agency of course we do
allow this torture staggering levels of
torture in the latest UNAMI report why
do you think the question should not be
put like this that we are allowing it
it's not like it's the government doing
everything possible has a major torture
center every year for at least eight
years what did you do with the reports
the progress you just good deep into
that report it tells you no staggering
something we understand the semantics
you know the way you put this words but
but the discussion I had here with the
UNAM were human rights people in this
office they told me that there is a
substantial improvement in this case
especially in Kandahar they spoke with
the commander of Police of Kandahar and
they assured them of every possible
cooperation who's been here's the test
who's been held to account as for
accountability we've only seen minor
disciplinary sanctions in the very few
cases that were investigated and no
compensation for victims despite a legal
requirement in your country to provide
that why why no compensation account for
me so in the case of the past you nama
reports there have been people from the
Indians in Kandahar from the police
department so I can give me the status
should they continue to torture then no
it's I think it's reducing anything off
scot-free that's the fact that you're
not
we are we have the most you know open
and volunteer apologists visa vie all
the united nation mechanisms of human
rights you know the the protocols the
optional protocol is the conventions and
the treaty bodies so it's it's like you
know Afghanistan have pledged that look
we have a very open and transparent
system of Human Rights yes there might
be you know it's not our committee there
might be no there might be capacity
problems there might be problems which
is you know the the the local somewhere
a local police is called you know
conducting maybe this some of these
crimes but it's not lack of it's
happening main intelligence Directorate
we're not talking about local police
just a few days ago you tweeted that the
Afghan government is fighting a complex
unconventional and asymmetrical war with
enemies that don't adhere to
international humanitarian law you
omitted to point out that your
government doesn't adhere to
international humanitarian law either
while no in contrary I said we commit to
every bit of IHL while our enemies on
paper but get into your prisons you
won't see much sign of international
humanitarian law I mean you can ask you
can ask human rights officers you can
ask you you nama and see you know how
we've just been it you're supposed to be
the good side of course we are in this
of course we are and you're abusing
torturing murdering stealing
disappearing people and the
international community mostly the US
has lost some 2,500 soldiers to protect
a government that allows this to go on
right we lost one hundred and fifty
thousand soldiers under store you see
you can put it in the broader prospect
I'm just why why the war is happening
there I mean you're coming to to to to a
details where you know it can
dv8 public opinion so if you look at
from their larger perspective while
United States and Afghanistan why we are
fighting who we are fighting with I mean
we are fighting with an enemy which
wanted to use each and every possible
mean to inflict pain on the civilians I
mean the lost casualties of 100 ordinary
people in a wedding hall I mean what can
justify that to justify any of the van
I'm trying to justify the things which
the Americans particularly have pointed
out like corruption where they claim you
are not doing enough and it doesn't help
that your president's national security
adviser Hamidullah muhib picked a fight
with the u.s. in March accusing their
peace negotiator mr. Khalil said of
acting out of personal ambition and
seeking to become Viceroy in a caretaker
government was that really such a good
idea to pick a fight with America you
see not fighting for you know the thing
is that you're not we are not fighting
with United State I mean that's that's
very well understand about the question
is they've rescinded a hundred and sixty
million dollars because they don't think
you're a partner who's fighting
corruption hundred and sixty million
dollars they've taken back no they're
not taking back their withhold s from
some of these projects exactly that's
and that's again that's a very technical
thing but such a Jeff state might pay
accused your government being unable to
manage transparently US government
resources and incapable of being a
partner that's a pretty stinging rebuke
isn't it you see there we are together
there is a framework called mutual
accountability I mean the government of
Afghanistan is ready and it's open if
there are problems those are shared
problems if they are progress that's a
shared progress but coming to the
relationship with the United States the
question is there is a peace process and
we all understand that the peace process
has at least two sides and one side is
the state and the government of
Afghanistan so we are saying that
without the state of government of
Afghanistan any peace process which will
grow and you know one-sided
is
you feel excluded you're excluded your
head because you see the negotiation has
two parts so one is the Taliban won't
sit down with you have to sit well you
can solve all the thing they have to but
they've said they won't yet the thing is
we all reality in the ground
Taliban are living probably in the 90s
sister I mean this is a different thing
they have to sit with the Afghan people
they have to sit with the African
government if they want to reach peace
with this you're not capable of
negotiating peace deals with your own
strong men and let alone the Taliban are
you that's why we have election that's
why we have if that solves anything
don't wait well last month both the US
and the Taliban appeared close to an
agreement and then Trump called off a
meeting at at Camp David you don't want
those talks to succeed do you they've
started again in Sweden I understand
there being new talks it's definitely
one that to succeed because you know one
thing we all understand that that we are
all sick and tired of war I mean this
was 18 years but I myself I epitomize a
generation of war I was 1 1979 just
before the Soviet invaded Afghanistan I
mean how long more this can continue we
all want peace but peace has to be
sustainable peace it's not sustainable
until unless all the stakeholders are
not coming together and agreeing on a
common vision for future of Afghanistan
Taliban cannot force their way in
through Kabul and cannot you know have
the draconian ideology and rule of the
past they also understand I mean I've
been involved in some of this peace
process negotiation and monster it's all
about light now I think they've shown no
sign that they're changing what so long
I think they have to change in peace you
know and you say they have to you have
to yes so there's no sign that they will
I don't I have seen change as far as
they're concerned they don't have to
know anything at least at least in level
of
Petric the discussions that we have we
have seen that there is an understanding
for the Taliban that they cannot have it
all the way they wanted I mean do you
accept
do you accept an ambassador at some
point if this war is to end you have to
enter a power-sharing agreement with the
Taliban do you accept that you see how
do you call it a power-sharing I will
say that you know the stated Taliban can
be part of the state institutions but
will it be through a power sharing will
it be through an election will it be
through any other mechanism I think
that's open for internalization as part
of the governing elite if it is if it is
as part of is an agreement as part of an
inter of gun negotiation yes the same
Taliban that continues killing your
people your civilians blowing up your
most valuable religious cultural sites
Taliban that will pass punished women by
whipping them and refusing to let them
go to school or work with men you really
think that's changing I mean if they
agree with a common vision of future of
Afghanistan which is you say we already
have you differ very much on what that
actually means don't you you see it's a
very far apart a negotiation is they
have their you know their stated
position we have our own stated position
but but we know as diplomat we expect
and we believe that there is a zone of
agreement where the two sides will come
to a consensus and that consensus will
not be something that they definitely
want and that would not be something
that everything that we want so that's
that's what the definition of a
negotiation is if we reach into a
negotiated agreement with the Taliban
where you know the overarching gains
that we had here in terms of human
rights in terms of inner
constitutionalism and governance for the
people back they would roll them back No
then they've had four million girls
school then then the two girls on school
of course that's not something that will
compromise who couldn't know I mean
women rights is a red line I think if
there is only one one red line and that
is the woman's right the woman has their
rights they are gay nerd themselves they
are fought for it in past 18 years even
in the past and this is not something
that neither I another you or
international community should
compromise ambassador thank you very
much for being on thank you
[Music]
you
[Music]